lambda parameters specify the noise strength and can be amplified. We can implement Z& with the following steps.
First, amplify circuit noise for several noise factors. Lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3, and so on. Run every noise amplified circuit to measure the
expectation value a of lambda 1, a of lambda 2, and so on. And then extrapolate back to the zero noise
limit, the expectation value a of zero.
The main challenge in successfully implementing Z& is to have an accurate model for noise in the expectation value
and to amplify the noise in a known way.
There are three common ways error amplification is implemented for Z& scale pulse duration via calibration
repeat gates in identity cycles and adding noise via sampling py channels.
We call the latter PA. Probabilistic error amplification is the best choice here because pulse stretching is very
computationally costly. Gate folding lacks theoretical guarantees in preserving noise bias. But PA can be
applied to any circuit that can be run with native noise factors but require learning the noise model. PA assumes
that the same layerbased noise model as probabilistic error cancellation.
However, it avoids the sampling overhead that scales exponentially with the circuit noise. To learn the noise model,
we must first identify the unique layers of two cubit operations in the circuit.
For each layer, poly twirl the two cubit gates to ensure that the noise is well described by a damping noise model.
repeat identity pairs of layers at varying depth and finally fit a fidelity or an error for each noise channel. And
of course, while I recommend understanding this method to some extent, doing it by hand in Qiskit is
much more simple as is shown in the tutorial. Now, finally, let's take a look at the plotted data. The dotted
gray line shows the exact results obtained with approximate classical methods with approximation error
converge to a low threshold. As you can see, the raw data for the different factors of noise we chose at the
beginning is a good ways away from this dotted line. The solid blue line shows the data taking into account our Z&
processing. And you can tell right away it's much closer to the exact results.
In summary, the noisy values show high deviation from the exact values. The
mitigated values are close to the exact values, demonstrating the utility of the pea based mitigation technique.
And that essentially concludes this episode. To quickly summarize what we have learned, quantum simulation is one
of the most promising application areas in the short to midterm.
It has wide ranging applications from pharmaceuticals to high energy physics,
material science and more. The utility paper from IBM published in 2023 pointed
the way towards being able to use quantum computers for scientific discovery. And we worked through the
associated tutorial that goes along with that paper in depth. The steps to work through a simulation problem from start
to finish are relatively straightforward, especially once you get the hang of it. And my hope is that you
can from now on use this video and the tutorial as a guide for even more simulation problems in the future.
Thanks for watching and we'll see you next time on Quantum Computing in Practice.